pectives bonsoir c'est mal rozès merci
d'être avec nous on connaissait
évidemment la grande fronde sociale les
grèves les mêmes mobilisation
mobilisation sur le terrain et puis ça y
est la fronde maintenant parlementaire
hier la gauche aujourd'hui la droite est
ce que l'étau se resserre clairement sur
l'exécutif sur ce projet de réforme des
retraites
alors ya un mécontentement de la gauche
et la droite c'est assez attendu au fond
après de longues semaines de mouvement
social sur les retraites le fait que
toujours deux français sur trois soient
opposés à la réforme
et puis il y a des signes de
fragilisation à l'intérieur même du
groupe parlementaire et donc il ya un
sentiment sur la réforme en général
qu'elle a mal été préparé après tout ce
temps quand même où il ya eu des
concertations autour de jean paul
delevoye est que dans la toute dernière
ligne droite
le parlement n'est ce pas et demander à
rapidement voté la loi de façon très
précipitée de sortie n'y aurait eu ni
réellement une séquence de dialogue
social il y aura eu des concertations
mais pas de dialogue et puis au plan du
parlement le sentiment qu'ils ne ratent
pas eu non plus enfin qu'il n'y a pas de
conditions pour 1 1
un débat parlementaire riche et avec le
temps nécessaire mais justement ça c'est
la nouveauté si j'ose dire c'est un
argument peut-être qui fait sens avant
on était dans l'opposition essayé d'
annoncer d'avancer ses arguments contre
cette réforme et maintenant on y voit là
on nous impose ça on a quatre jours
est-ce que c'est justement l'argument
qui peut faire mouche et conduire au
retrait avec le conseil d'état on
rappelle qu'ils sont aimés les hier non
je ne crois pas que les rapports de
force au sein du parlement le permettent
mais au fond il ya pour sans doute le
président et le gouvernement
actant au fond une forme d'impopularité
l'idée qu' il représenterait au moins à
la fois l'ordre et à la fois le
sentiment que même un fond des choses il
réforme le pays
comme si c'était pour les français une
finalité en soi pour les français la
réforme est un moyen au service d'une
vision et la l'exécutif semble être mû
par l'idée de il faut avancer et c'est
au pays de s'adapter c'est aux forces
politiques de s'adapter c'est aux
partenaires sociaux de s'adapter comme
si le mouvement il était en soi pour le
l'exécutif une finalité est ce que c'est
la réforme qui va qui risque de faire
perdre
l'exécutif en tout cas la majorité aux
municipales on voit un sondage assez peu
encourageants pour emmanuel macron paru
chez oddo ksa trois français sur 10 qui
veulent sanctionner le président de la
république aux prochaines municipales
oui alors il faut il faut faire
attention à ce type de sondage c'est 2
l'ancien directeur d'un sondage qui m'en
parlent parce que en fait ces
municipales d'ailleurs a été le problème
d'incompréhension du président macron le
verra peut-être si on parle des
principales villes où il ya des
dissensions
ces municipales plus qu'aucune autre les
motivations de vote sont pas du tout des
motivations nationales ou sur des
étiquettes mais au contraire sur des
personnes sur des crochets donc bien sûr
il y à des questions des formulations
des questions et des priorisations ou
pas des questions aussi le climat
national devait peser ce sera un climat
national anti gouvernement mais cette
variable ne va pas être la variable
principal ici emmanuel macron et la
république en marche ont des problèmes
aux municipales c'est à mon avis sans
doute beaucoup plus qu'ils n'ont pas à
soi trouver des bons candidats soit par
ci n'ont pas d'ancrage local
suffisamment importante pour que leur
candidat puisse mener dans de bonnes
conditions
une campagne basée sur des enjeux locaux
est-ce que la république en marche est
en train de déchanter cet enthousiasme
qu'on a connu à la présidentielle on
voit l'hémorragie au sein de de ce parti
il ya un des champions un réel subit
absolument vous avez tout à fait raison
il ya maintenant eu environ 12 députés
qui ont quitté la république en marche
ne sais pas s'ils vont rester apparentés
s'ils vont faire quelque chose d'autre
mais au fond quand le maquereau nice
m'arrive c'est une sorte de licorne
politique une sorte d'objet nos
d'identifier et quand le lien entre le
président qui est arrivé sur une postion
un peu néo bonapartiste de rapport
direct avec le pays ceux d'édith alors
c'est tout ce qu'il y a entre les deux
dans la ma chronique qui est du coup
absolument bousculer
alors on le voit dans les défections de
députés qui fit à un rythme maintenant
plus important la république en marche
et on le voit dans le fait que le tiers
des villes de 50 des 50 premières villes
il ya des dissidences alors on pense
évidemment à la dissidence paris mais il
ya paris lyon marseille toulouse et nice
par exemple dans les villes les plus
importantes ou au fond le candidat
retenu même si c'est un maire sortant
d'ailleurs de droite en général ça ne
passe pas et donc il ya des velléités de
personnes qui étaient la république en
marche de présenter leurs propres bus
comment justement vous expliquer ces
dissidents et commencer à nous donner
une explication mais prenons le cas de
paris effectivement c'est emblématique
il n'y a pas d'autorité de légitimité
benjamin griveaux a été a été choisi et
finalement ne respecte pas ce choix
alors il ya on l'a dit tout à l'heure le
fait que le président dans son lien ou
pays a perdu beaucoup de la confiance
dont il a bénéficié pendant un an il
pouvait réformer parce qu'il avait une
vision pas s'ils semblaient tenu par ce
qu'était le peuple français
alors bon qu'on considérait que ces
réformes pourraient être injuste
socialement
le pays qu'on sentait parce qu'il
semblait vouloir restaurer la
souveraineté de la nation
à partir du moment où angela merkel
l'empêchent d'avoir ce deuxième étape de
construction du maquereau nisme il
semble reprendre la politique de ses
prédécesseurs et donc du coup avec les
gilets jaunes et la réforme des
retraites du coup la question de la
justice sociale devient à nouveau
prééminente alors qu'est-ce qui se passe
il se passe que d'habitude
en tout cas pour les grandes villes le
président de la république
antérieurement il suivait tous les
dossiers prenons paris benjamin griveaux
a une mauvaise image
cédric villani avait la meilleure image
auprès des parisiens le score de
benjamin griveaux tient essentiellement
à ce que
on sait que le président est derrière
benjamin griveaux mais au moment de la
décision sans doute que les arbitrages
qui ont été choisis n'ont pas été les
bons donc on sentait un président de la
république qui voulait pas trop rentrer
dans les détails de ces questions de
candidature n'est pas parce qu'on sait
que ça n'intéresse pas énormément le
président mais il n'était pas dans une
situation telle avec dans son rapport
aux pays qui pouvait laisser sous
traiter ça donc
en un mot à paris des choses se sont
très mal passé parce que elles n'ont pas
été du point de vue de l'image des
candidats auprès des parisiens et le
fait de savoir qui pouvait porter un
projet alternatif à l'image mauvaise
d'ailleurs de la maire sortante anne
hidalgo à lord en même temps il ya quand
même des chiffres encourageants la
baisse du chômage la france attractive
en europe ça veut dire que les français
ne regarde même plus ça ne voit plus ces
bonnes nouvelles vous avez tout à fait
raison de mettre en avant les
améliorations objectif d'un pays mais au
fond ça ramène à des questions beaucoup
plus profond de d'où vient la dépression
française alors moi ça fait des années
que je dis que selon moi cette
dépression n'a pas des raisons
essentiellement économiques et sociales
la france même s'ils savent son modèle
social est dégradée est dans une
situation très avantageuses
et d'ailleurs beaucoup de nos amis
européens en ville associations
françaises il vaut mieux être un salarié
français qu'un salarié allemand
nous répondrons pas d'ajustement alors
justement alors tout bien cette
dépression et bien justement n'ont pas
de situation objective économique et
social vous avez indiqué situation
d'amélioration mais parce que ce qui
depuis des siècles à tient en france
ensemble des français c'est le rapport
au politique
c'est le politique qui est en crise les
français pour déployer leurs chili pour
clients un bonheur collectif des
français doivent avoir le sentiment
qu'ils maîtrisent
leurs destins qui se projette dans le
monde que c'est eux qui nous sommes sûrs
à l'arte france depuis napoléon à il
compterait jusqu'à moscou où avant même
les croisades le type de rapport à la
colonisation le type de rapport à
l'europe
les français doivent se dire que le
monde ait la france en grand or le
sommet de l'état bercy le logiciel
culturel de bercy de bruxelles et de
berna
c'est tout l'inversé le sommet de l'état
demande à damnation d'intérioriser le
monde extérieur alors que la france elle
la nation a besoin de se projeter à
l'extérieur et c'est selon moi cette
raison éminemment culturelle qui fait la
dépression française emmanuelle max nom
semblait la résoudre puisqu'il avait dit
que le problème c'était pas de français
c'était la classe politique un an après
il reprend le logiciel de bercy de
bruxelles qu'il avait lui-même dénoncé
la politique du rabot la politique des
3%
le fétichisme budgétaire donc selon moi
la dépression française a des raisons
culturelles avant tout et non pas
économique et social est ce que si on
vous suit ça sera ma dernière question
est ce que c'est un boulevard à l'avenir
pour les partis disent souverainistes
entre nîmes et populiste ça fait déjà de
nombreux mois que je pense qu'à ce
train-là évidemment puisque marine le
pen elle-même opère une mutation du
nationalisme à la nation on l'a bien vu
lors des européennes que le président
bak rond en cas de deuxième tour face à
marine le pen ne pourrait pas compter
sur le réflexe initial anti marine le
pen et c'est à mon avis par la
mésestimation de sa poule commet une
erreur de vouloir y aller au forceps
aidés par les institutions dans ses
réformes et et au fond
l'idée que la france n'aurait qu'à
s'adapter au monde extérieur ce qui est
justement ce qui entraîne en retour une
volonté de reprise en main de notre
destin
autour de la question de la souveraineté
nationale mais aussi beaucoup stéphane
rozès président de cap 1 pour votre
analyse merci à vous